in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Andre
and Gilda are with us hey how are you
hey Dave welcome honored to have you
guys where do you live
Lantana Texas all right very fun and
what's that near Dallas it's about 30
miles northwest of Dallas Texas okay
cool yeah no right where you are it's a
wonderful area yeah we're back and forth
to Dallas feels like a second home down
there these days we're burning the
burning the airline miles back and forth
well welcome you guys so you're here to
do your debt-free scream yeah cool how
much have you paid off that's a little
over four hundred and five thousand and
then last four and a half years Wow oh
you killed it and what kind of range of
income during that time uh north of 250
whoa what do you guys do for a living
I'm a clinical pharmacist at one of the
hospitals there's part of it okay and
I'm a pharmacist as well I'm in pharmacy
management both of your kick in it okay
very great careers Wow
so did you meet in pharmacy school yes
yeah okay very cool fun you're somewhat
steady partner uh-huh there you go
that'll that'll cause trouble over time
sir so what kind of debt was that four
hundred and five thousand our house and
a car all right so you're a debt free
house and everything amen what's the
house worth about 550 or so awesome very
cool and how long you guys been on a
pharmacy school oh oh okay a ways away
all right yeah so what happened
four-and-a-half years ago you decided to
kick it in gear here well I have to give
credit to a colleague of mine Gary
Fulton he and I were at a Leadership
Conference at the hospital and through
the course of us eating lunch with each
other he asked me out I ever heard of
Dave Ramsey and I said name sounds
vaguely familiar but no and he said I
you know judging from what you talked
about and things you've said I think
you'd really connect with him and I'm
gonna bring you something I said okay
next day he brought me in a packet a set
it on my desk Financial Peace University
whoa and my Center he went all in yeah
and he had been into it for a while had
left some classes and left me with
information and and I took to it like
water to fish the water and just jumped
in hit first came home I listened to a
few of them before I talked with guilt
about it I came home and let's just say
I asked her how much she was in love
with her vehicle because we had not long
before then purchased her a brand new
MDX
I would have been in love with that
vehicle that's we know didn't you didn't
well making 250 with no house payments
or anything you can get you another one
pretty quick oh my goodness gracious
what did it bring umm well we just asked
for what it was what was old on it it
was I think it's about 40 grand that was
on their own in and we got it what made
you decide to do that I trusted this man
right here and I loved him and I
believed in him and what he told he was
going to get us out of debt and that
when we got out of debt I can have
whatever I wanted there you go that's a
good trade that's a good good good
carrot there good carrot Andre good job
nice job so and obviously for the last
25 years life's been pretty good for you
to have that level of trust absolutely
yeah very good merit my best friend you
did awesome that's fun stuff so when
people hear that you're completely dead
free house you're just weird I mean
you're weird it's awesome when they hear
you did that and they say how did you do
that Gilda what do you tell them the
secret was for y'all getting out of that
the secrets are getting out of debt was
first just believing that we could do it
you know that's big I saw and heard
other people doing it and I was like if
they can do it we can do it also and
then I just trusted in Andre and what he
said we were going to do he'd say we're
gonna be debt-free just trust me and I
did and then I had a great my husband is
incredible man but I also had an amazing
father who was an entrepreneur himself
he had his own business and I saw him
sit at the table and write on a budget
all the time and he told me the first
thing you do you pay God you pay your
tithes you save money you pay yourself
and you pay your bills and Dave my dad
did not know you
he had the envelope system his was his
pouch it was a zippered pouch and he
always put money into this pouch to save
for things that were needed and he
didn't have credit cards didn't believe
in credit cards so if we didn't have the
money in that pouch we didn't get it I
liked so when he came home and he said
we got this dudas envelope system and we
have to write out a budget I was all-in
yeah that's when he was wise and he had
money that's right yeah very cool that's
good very good
so Andre what do you tell people the
secret to this is well I think it all
comes down
perseverant today but I'm you know we
were both blessed to have good parenting
different different situations but good
parenting my mom was an educator
never earned a whole lot of money
struggled to go back and finish her
degree to begin with but my mom was my
living example perseverance and her
thought process in a way she carried
herself really just laid a foundation in
me and so for me over these last four
and a half years us saying no was really
just us saying yes to our future yeah
and and so we're excited about it yeah
you're living like no one else so later
you can live and give like no one else
Wow well I'm sure your mom and your dad
are really proud right now I'm sure
they're watching you very very cool
I'm so proud of you too so we're gonna
give you a copy of Chris Hogan's book
signed and because that's the next step
is to become extremely wealthy and
change your family tree live your dreams
and be outrageously generous way above
and beyond the tithe and you guys Chris
will show you how to do that with return
inspired number one bestseller give you
a copy of that thank you for making the
trip all the way from Dallas Texas area
I
during Gilda four hundred and five
thousand dollars paid off they paid off
their house people I love it
four and a half years making 250 a year
a couple of pharmacists count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
praise be to God
I love it good one guys very very very
well done man that's fun hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind